hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today we have a little bit of
a different video to talk about
Borderlands 3 gameplay trailer and
gameplay showcase was shown off today at
one of their conventions that they had
and seeing as I've been a very avid fan
of Borderlands way back since the
beginning of Borderlands 1 and still
play the game today I thought it'd be
really nice to hop in and show some of
the gameplay and kind of what my
thoughts are as well as try to cover
this game in the future if you guys like
real quick though there will be a couple
boss fights within the video but do not
worry if you don't want to have any
spoilers right before the boss encounter
in the video starts I'll have a time
skip that you can skip all that if you
want to know the story and you don't
want to hear that that's completely
understandable I totally get you with
that we as always like the V if you do
enjoy subscriber for new my Twitter and
discord will be in the description down
below and let's get started into piecing
together what is happening with
Borderlands 3 come September 13th so
first a really really cool thing that
they added for twitch streamers and I
believe it's just twitch streamers in
general maybe it is if you want to
stream on YouTube but it's a I believe
it's something called the echo net
stream setup so this is you can see the
streamers loot from they're equipped
items to their inventory in real time
with loads of other guns and Borderlands
it could be really hard to answer that
to get an answer to your question of Oh
what gun is he or she using so instead
of asking the streamer and having them
answer 80,000 questions per stream you
can now use the echo net stream set up
and you can think and you can kind of
see a solid idea of what they're using
and kind of how they're gonna use it in
game which is really sick and I cannot
wait to try that out and also if you do
download it and you do watch a stream or
you can actually gain some loot for you
to use during borderlands 3 and you can
even use it now so you can get some loot
before the game even launches but first
up we have the first piece of gameplay
in Borderlands 3 and as you can tell
claptrap is back in the game which is
great to know everyone pretty much
already knew this but if you needed
confirmation to our little yellow robot
when he is still in the game so expect
just as many comedic one-liners as usual
from him and on top of that there's
going to be a new cult called the
children of the vault which is really
interesting
they're very mysterious there there
isn't much info about them as of yet but
we're gonna be learning a lot more
throughout the story when the game does
release here's the quick change menu
before it used to be the head the skin
and then respecting with your name and
now it has loads of other things like
changing your head
your skin color and new echo themes and
emotes which you can use which are not
in previous games this is of course add
some flair and a co-op play if you want
to interact like that and then also
they're taking you through this tutorial
learning a few things about the game
being used to it there is no green
highlight anymore for new objectives
it's gonna be a little yellow sparkle
and now they've added the addition of
sliding and mantling into the game
allowing for more environmental
techniques because if you've never
played a Borderlands game before the
only type of environmental techniques
that we could really use was crouching
and jumping so now they've added way
more stuff to that and here's the new UI
for weapons and items it looks roughly
the same except with a little few nicer
looking details really big fan of that
and some guns also have an alternate
firing mode for example this blatt off
pistol has an alternate fire where
instead of shooting bullets you can
shoot mini micro missiles some of them
also have mines explosions the tdr
weapons are incredibly weird we'll get
to that little bit later in the video
but there's a lot of different things
you can use so even more different
weapons in the game adding to the
bazillion of weapons we already have so
it's gonna mean a lot more grinding for
the specific weapon you want but I think
it's all in good fun anyway
one thing I noticed throughout the
gameplay is that with cover it can
actually degrade and be completely gone
if enough damage is dealt to it on top
of that there you can also punch barrels
to launch them and explode as opposed to
smacking it and then it blows up as
before in Borderlands 1 - in the pre
sequel next up is gonna it be the mini
boss fight again like I said if you do
want if you don't want to spoil yourself
for the first boss in the game you can
click into the time stamp at the bottom
right you can go to that time and it'll
skip you right through this part but if
you do want to continue on the first
boss of the game his name is Shiv and he
is a badass Psycho physique and of
course after he drops he can do some
loot he looks like a really cool boss
but of course he's pretty easy within
the game so I don't expect nothing too
crazy probably like knuckle dragger kill
him in like a minute or two if that so
he probably won't drop too much loop of
who knows maybe in the higher
difficulties he may actually be able to
drop some of the good items like how
knuckle dragger kind of Borderlands 2 so
who knows maybe we'll find that out
later before the game releases but in
Borderlands 3 the one thing about
reviving in with NPCs is that they
actually can't revive you and you can't
revive them so they're basically there
for no reason but now in Borderlands 3
you can now or 5 NPCs if they go to
and they can also now revive you so your
npc won't stand there and do nothing
kind of like rollin in the dragon keep
DLC as to not be a little bit boring
they did skip a little bit ahead in the
story to a place called ascension Bluff
this is roughly a level 7 area in the
game and the whole objective of this
place is that you want to go here to
find a key which can lead to future
vaults throughout the entire universe
and also instead of having one action
skill you can now have 3 action skills
in the game for example the new siren in
the game Amara has of a few things like
phase grasp which is exactly like Maya's
from Borderlands 2 face cast is a clone
to kill people and face slam is a big
ground pound you can buy augments to
enhance these skills with skill points
and every time you level up so you can
interchange these three skills depending
on which one you want I can I can
totally see this being used in solo play
depending on the scenario it might be a
little bit tedious going to the
inventory screen swapping out the skills
and coming back but it might actually be
pretty useful one other small bit of
information that I noticed is that
Hyperion shotguns now have shields on
them to provide extra cover when aiming
this actually wasn't the case in
Borderlands 2 and radiation is a new
element type I'm not really sure if this
replaces they already existing element
like slag because I've heard from other
rumors and leaks that slag might
actually be gone from Borderlands 3 so I
don't know if this is gonna be a
standalone
type of element and add it to the whole
roster of stuff that we have fire shock
explosion corrosion and stuff like that
or if it's going to get rid of slag
because of this leak that's coming up
but either way radiation looks really
cool I can't wait to have some weapons
with that if there is any weapons with
that element and one super huge thing is
that co-op play is now viable and I'm
gonna try to explain that a little bit
of course co-op play in Borderlands has
always been viable but it's always been
an issue when you're a low-level
character and your high-level buddy
wants to play with you but he's just
clean sweeping all the enemies or vice
versa you go into his game and you're
getting absolutely stomped because all
the enemies are higher or lower and
stuff like that it's just not a whole
fun experience and especially if you're
the higher level guy you're not going to
be getting any good items because you're
just helping your friend carry you or
carry your friend throughout the game
but it's a new type of system called
loot initiation each player gets their
own loot for example in this game play
Amara is level 5 and this pistol is
level 5 but Flint here is level 25 and
he looked
the exact same pistol and it's not level
25 for him so every player gets their
own loot and it scales to their rank
which is beautiful and if you don't
really like this type of style you can
of course go back to the old game mode
there is a game mode in Borderlands 3
called classic mode which is the old
Borderlands gameplay which can be super
useful for power leveling new characters
or power leveling your friends to get
where they're at if they don't want to
do that anymore so that is totally there
just like old times if you do want to
have that type of mode for zane they
looked a little bit of his skills and he
has a lot of different skills like
decoys a drone and a barrier that can
add elements if you shoot through the
barrier he can also equip two augments
and two actions goes at once like a
barrier and a drone unlike amara at the
time who can only equip one and I'm not
sure if this is just based off of a
character or it's because Flint in the
gameplay is level 25 and amaras only
level 5 in this gameplay so maybe that
is a character thing in Flint of courses
like maybe the only character that can
do this or the higher you level up the
more augments that you can use and the
more action skills that you can have in
the game so that maybe you can have all
three at one time but that wasn't
actually clearly explained but in terms
of fighting with this stuff it is
actually still viable just like the loot
thing Flint is fighting enemies that are
level 25 but Amara is fighting enemies
that are level 5 and his damage is
balanced that he isn't stomping all
these enemies because I'm assuming at
level 25 you're not doing 10 to 11
damage on an opponent but since this is
a Mara's game and she is level 5 they're
gonna balance the damage to that and I'm
assuming if it was vice versa where if
it was Flint's game I know Mar is the
lower level and flint is higher her
damage might be a little bit higher even
though her weapon can definitely not get
that much damage out of that gun at that
level overall it makes co-op play a lot
less stressful and it can actually be
really helpful because in the in terms
of Borderlands 2 right now I'm about a
level 58 on my new character so I have
to basically wait for all my friends to
catch up to me and if I want to power
level them I have to go through or no XP
they get all the loot it's pretty boring
now I can play with them at any single
time in the game and we can all earn
lose together so I'm not wasting my time
and they showed off the TDR weapons next
and if you remember what TDR weapons
were those are the weapons that didn't
need to reload and you can whip them and
throw them for explosive damage now they
have even more stuff and TD or has
branching out to improve their
technology we have Gert we have guns
that can walk guns that can bounce guns
that can shoot missiles out of it
allowing for absolute complete
destruction and especially with the
walking gun you can throw multiple at
once have three or four on the bet on
the battlefield you could just
annihilate the entire enemy force in
front of you moving a little bit farther
they went to the ammo Sheen's and
instead of having to go into the menu
and select every single type of ammo
individually you can help press a single
button which in this case was the Y
button for xbox I'm assuming that's
triangle for Pete for ps4 you can now
press that button and you will get all
the ammo maxed out to that ammo type
instead of going individually which
saves a hell of a lot of time and I'm
very glad that they're adding that part
and then they also mentioned that
they're going to be adding a lot more
bosses mini-bosses regular bosses raid
bosses just to incur increase the loop
pool and just have a lot of fun because
fighting bosses in this game is very fun
just fighting bosses in general is a lot
of fun because those guys give you a lot
more loot a lot more XP and it's just a
hell of a lot of fun in general once
again we're gonna get to the second boss
fight so once again and this will be the
last boss fight of the video so if you
do want to skip this and not prove it
and not see any spoilers you can click
the timestamp in the bottom right or you
can go to that timer and you will be
able to go and skip this entire boss
fight but once again the next boss fight
is going to be mouthpiece mouthpiece has
a shield and a load of speakers on the
outskirts of this little DJ arena that
he has this to disorient you in the
fight mouthpiece doesn't seem like a
crazy fight but looks really awesome and
here's the gun he was using in the fight
it's pretty great that you can actually
kill bosses in the game and use their
weapons as your own so that's really
nice and then after you defeat
mouthpiece the Calypso twins who are the
new boss antagonists in the game and now
appear and talk to you and as the dev
stated they're like the shitty streamers
on Twitch that no one really likes the
really cocky really [ __ ] ish so
that's kind of how these guys are
talking because when you first enter the
area they can't they talk as if they
were just ending one of their streams on
Twitch so they're kind of like these
guys and the kind that children of the
vault are kind of like their followers
or their cult members but to go to other
places in the map there is a ship and
it's not called sanctuary 3 and this is
where you can fast travel to any other
planets in the world as well as other
places and see a lot of stuff within
there there is a new vending machine
where it drops all of your missed stuff
on the adventure which is really
incredible so if you happen to miss a
legendary or didn't have enough
to pick up that pink or purple that
dropped that will come into that machine
and that means you will never have to
kind of think about what weapons you
want to drop because it'll all come back
to you eventually on the safety of the
ship in sanctuary and now instead of
Earl or Steve I completely forget his
name I believe it's crazy or I could
totally be wrong if memory serves me
right I hope it's Earl but he is now not
he is still in the game but he is not
going to be giving us our ammo capacity
and her backpack capacity and stuff like
that that you would normally purchase
with iridium Marcus is now taking that
over and you can now buy it with money
which is a hell of a lot easier because
while iridium isn't really that hard to
find and farming Borderlands do it's way
easier to buy it with money and I'm
assuming the higher you go up it's gonna
be pretty expensive maybe in the
millions and stuff like that as for
people within the area you can best
believe that Moxie has her own bar back
at the ship Tanis is back inside of a
dead corpse I don't know why she was
there
Maya's here hammerlock's here Ellie is
here there's probably a hell of a lot
more people within the ship that they
haven't shown us so maybe scooters here
the other characters like brick and
mortar Kai might be here and maybe some
of the other characters from Borderlands
2 might also be there as well so that's
gonna be really cool to see a little bit
later in the gameplay they showed a
Mara's room and since this is sort of
gameplay this is our quarters and of
course I'm assuming when you play in
co-op mode you have your own different
rooms that you can check out and you can
make it look as flashy as you want put
down a trophy put down your favorite gun
your most rare gun on the wall make your
area very specific to you and make it
look really nice that is kind of what
the whole point of the quarters room is
so that people can check it out but like
I said on this spaceship you can travel
and fast travel to planets like
Prometheus or example that's just one of
the planets of the many that are gonna
be happening with Borderlands 3 and that
also means that the world of Borderlands
3 is going to be absolutely huge I'm
assuming to avoid clutter you're going
to be able to fast travel to certain
planets and then go within their
atmosphere and then you can travel to
those individual locations they skipped
again through midway through the game
and you're now at a new planet called
Promethea and you're gonna be a little
bit halfway through this planet at the
Meridian complex and basically the story
with this is that the manufacturers of
all the element weapons in the game
Mally 1 are taking over this area and
they're using a lot of their forces to
take it over so there's gonna be a lot
of Malley one chest that doesn't really
mean much because you can still get Vlad
off gun
tt your guns Jacobs guns from these but
the chest will have the Mallee one logo
in it that's really the only difference
there and closer towards the end before
they cut off the stream of the gameplay
my boy zero is back kicking ass as usual
not saying [ __ ] because he's quiet as
hell so he's definitely gonna be back in
the game I'm assuming we're gonna be
able to get some of these NPCs
throughout the game and recruit them
back into sanctuary just like we did
with Borderlands 2 where we recruited
roland lilith mordecai and brick to come
back to the crimson raiders i'm assuming
this is going to be the exact same thing
because as i stated before maya was on
the ship for Borderlands 2 so I'm
assuming that zero went off and did more
assassination missions Creed gage
Salvador Axton all those people I don't
know where they are in the ship or even
if we're on the ship maybe we can
recruit them and bring them back that'd
be really cool to see
and then lastly they have played the
gameplay trailer which I'll leave in the
background and showed some of the new
areas within the we can see banded
technicals turrets varkids
all new types of enemies appearing and
even new one-wheeled vehicles which we
saw in a couple screenshots it also
looks like you can hijack bandit
technicals judging but this could just
be some flashy stuff for the trailer so
this may or may not be a thing and they
also showed some more bosses no names of
course as to not spoil anything but it
definitely looks like a boss room and
they even shown another character FLAC
who I'm definitely going to be playing
as soon as the game drops he they showed
a couple of his abilities some of the
pets he can spawn and even this
weird-ass mech suit which I have no clue
where that I got this from how this game
into the game but I'm very excited to
use it maybe this will be only in
specific story missions or you can use
this all the time I would love to see
how this comes into play with the game
and maybe makes the boss fight a little
bit harder or easier depending on the
boss and then one last note to end the
video the devs did a little small
talking and of small Q&A and the one
thing they mentioned is that they
promised that the DLC in this game will
be great there's going to be lots of it
very similar to Borderlands 2 and
there's not going to be any
microtransactions within the game which
of course is very rare to hear in 2019
in terms of video games which but is it
always very welcomed within the
community of course because not many
people are liking microtransactions and
people are absolutely sick of them and
there's also going to be showings of the
game throughout the summer so definitely
keep an eye on the channel for that I'll
try to cover anything new that they talk
about maybe a new boss new weapons
anything like that so definitely stay on
the channel for that be a guys that's
going to
the end of the day I hope you guys did
enjoy it like I said that's gonna be the
borderlands 3 gameplay the first look of
the borderlands 3 gameplay and kind of
what we can expect when we hop into the
game let me know who you guys are gonna
play with in borderlands 3 just judging
off some of the characters like I said
I'm gonna be playing flak but I think my
secondary might be Flint I'm liking this
whole soldier vibe he got from it I'm
like Devlin to Amara and maybe the other
character I completely forgot her name
uh sorry about that but I think flack is
gonna definitely be a character I'll be
playing a lot of yeah let me know your
thoughts on Borderlands 3 how it looks
is it gonna you got you guys hyped for
the game I'm of course like for the game
seeing as I'm posting it and I'm
actually about to go as soon as this
video is done go farm some Borderlands 2
bosses cuz I'm eagerly waiting for
Borderlands there to come out and I
cannot contain this hype anymore but
it's always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I'll try to
cover a lot more stuff within
Borderlands whether it be guides lore
builds news all that type of stuff just
try to find myself within the community
so if you guys want me to do a lot more
Borderlands games and content like that
definitely let me know in the comments
below my Twitter and discord will be in
the description if you guys want to join
those that'd be highly appreciated and
with that take care guys enjoy the rest
of your day and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]